days before the July phone call between  Donald Trump and the Ukrainian president  Donald Trump ordered military aid be  withheld from Ukraine with a black  circle potentially a Sharpie used to  draw in a section of the Florida  Panhandle and pieces of Alabama  stand back and stand by the Mueller  report there is an incredible amount of  evidence of obstruction  extraordinarily damaging the Donald  Trump into the people around him so  interesting to see quote Progressive  Democrat congresswoman who originally  came from countries whose governments  are a complete and total catastrophe the  worst why don't they go back and help  fix the totally broken and  crime-infested places from which they  came